[Music]
foreign
so looking at tons and tons of comments
from past videos one of the main
questions that arises is will we ever
see the mutuals again in the future
those hideously beautiful black monsters
that captured our attention from the
very first scene when the mail broke out
from its cocoon captivating our
imaginations throughout the length of
the first movie The sleek and sector yet
extraterrestrial-like design you know I
hope it's not just me but when I saw the
mutual male take flight in 2014
I initially thought that legendary had
up Mothra in Hollywood but
thankfully it was another Kaiju a new
novel Kaiju so let's talk a little bit
on what they are their forms just to get
people on the same page and we will
discuss their possible appearances in
the upcoming most of us flicks so let's
get to it
just for recap let's take a brief look
at their Origins and the four types of
miros that are present in the master
verse so these monsters are super
species or Titans are ancient creatures
which feed on radiation be it from the
earth or from other Titans they are
species that have specifically evolved
to hunt down and kill the Gojira species
to further their own reproductive cycle
that is they need a Gojira species to
lay their spores in so that the young
ones will develop in a radiation-rich
body but the form that does this is the
prime form the muto Prime the hawk
mutual and the femmeadow are sexual
stages of their species life cycle
whereby they mate and lay eggs this
cycle is a little bit complex just know
that there are four stages the nymphs
the dimorphic sexual stage the queen
stage in kotm and the mutual prime stage
so why are the mutual so beloved as a
gaiju species well for one they are a
unique novel creation by legendary a
break from the classic Touhou monsters
like Rodan Mothra Ghidorah and the rest
they appear as insecto Giants but also
empowered by radiation as well as being
able to create electromagnetic pulses
that is taught and disrupt electronic
hardware and not just that but they can
also dampen the strength of a nuclear
reaction by either siphoning the energy
for themselves or just outright lower
the nuclear output as seen when
Godzilla's iconic Atomic breath became
just a sort of a flamethrower they are
also fan favorites for their design they
are jet black in coloration with glowing
red eyes who doesn't love that and they
have six limbs which are just awesome no
need to explain why the other two forms
the queen and Prime are a little bit
different they are more of a lighter
grayish black coloration and appear to
be more rugged but still stunningly
breathtaking thank you now before
discussing their possible future
appearances in the upcoming most of us
series and movies we will first address
the elephant in the room that is what is
the relation between the queen and the
prime is the queen Miro just a precursor
form or is it a baby of the prime or is
it something else well KDM monsters and
Arvin Nelson had a discussion on Twitter
with them confirming that the queen is
in fact a nymph form of the Prime just
ask the Motorola and the Imago form are
two separate forms of the same species
so yeah this brings out the possibility
that a future Muto Prime May yet appear
again in the most of us as there is
still a surviving member of a species
therefore the legacy of these monsters
is still up and added if a queen Mewtwo
morphs into a prime then there is a
possibility that another Prime might
eventually lay its pose in Godzilla and
their sexual stages might arise again in
the future and the whole charade it
continues as is the way of Nature and
life
now will we see Prime in the Godzilla
series the legacy of monsters well what
do we really know about the series and
its timeline
the synopsis says that it was set after
the battle between Godzilla and the
Titans the mutos revealing that monsters
are real and the show follows one
family's journey to uncover its buried
secrets and Legacy linking them to
Monarch so any guess as to what talent
that Godzilla fought immediately after
the mutos in San Francisco in the same
year in 2014 well none other than an
ancient awakened Mutual Prime there is
let's say a 99 probability that we are
going to see the battle from Godzilla
off the shock in live action it would be
a huge fail for the series if this fight
wasn't shown it would defeat the notion
of the legacy of monsters especially the
word legacy as we now know the legacy of
the muted species the prime and the
various life stages
yeah there's also a one percent
probability that we might not get the
chance to see this epic showdown but my
gut says otherwise of course we will be
traveling with the characters as they
unravel the world of the Titans and the
secret Monarch organization we might see
the sleeping Titans the ones that were
awakened by Ghidorah and kotm Titans
like Behemoth mukile and bembe maybe
even x-ray scans of Methuselah and you
know Monster Zero in his hibernation
state but we all know that these Titans
only came back to the fall of the kotm
and that the only active ones between
2014 and 2019 are Godzilla gong the
Skull Island creatures Mark Giger and
the mutual Prime therefore Prime must
appear or else I'm gonna dance naked in
front of a live audience here in mind Q
I'm just kidding I read a girl up in a
fetal position and cry
on a serious note now will we see the
queen Muto or the prime again in
Godzilla X Kong the new Empire as of now
we have four Titans confirmed for the
movie that is Godzilla Kong Scar the red
Kong and shimu the original one
interesting thing is that the music
Queen is still alive and kicking about
and I think it's about damn time that we
see a morphing scene again but this time
we might or might not get to see the end
product it depends on the series if
Prime appears in Legacy of the monsters
then we might only see the queen in gxk
but if Prime isn't in the series then we
will definitely see a Morphin in the
movie maybe a battle between the meter
prime against either the good talents or
the evil ones with the prime being
Nature's neutral stance the balance
between the light side and the dog a
Darth Vader of the monster verse
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates or new
videos right here on this channel take
care fam